foreign
is really interesting if you go into it
deeply enough
when I first read this quote it had a
profound effect on me my whole life was
constantly motivated by the search of
the miraculous moments of ecstasy
moments of higher truth moments of high
significance when such moments failed to
Define my experience life was engulfed
by the mundane but the mundane can often
be just a fragment of our perception
sometimes the miraculous can't be found
in the mundane and finding the
miraculous in the mundane constitutes an
inflection point in one's life we are
brainwashed to believe that a good life
is a life filled with constant
stimulation with a lot of highs and a
lot of lows but is it really that way
when we slow down we notice things that
seemed Elusive and outside the periphery
of our Consciousness the world around us
becomes an endless territory ready to be
explored that's the best way to battle
unknowing and the person who made me
shift my perception toward knowing and
unknowing was no other than Richard
Feynman
Richard Feynman was one of the most
celebrated physicists of the previous
century and a person known as the great
explainer physics for him was a
playground through which he could
discover the world around him as he said
in physics the truth is rarely perfectly
clear and that is certainly universally
the case in human Affairs hence what is
not surrounded by uncertainty cannot be
the truth Feynman healed uncertainty at
the epicenter of his intellectual life
it is imperative he wrote to have
uncertainty as a fundamental part of
your inner nature this kind of mindset
is incredibly empowering when the most
Brilliant Minds feel comfortable with
uncertainty this clearly communicates
that it is an attitude worth adopting
I can live without and uncertainty and
not knowing I think it's much more
interesting
to live not knowing than to have answers
which might be wrong
I have approximate answers and possible
beliefs and different degrees of
certainty about different things but I'm
not absolutely sure of anything and then
many things I don't know anything about
but I don't have to know an answer I
don't have I don't feel frightened by
not knowing things
by being lost in the mysterious human
race without having any purpose which is
the way it really is as far as I can
tell possible it doesn't frighten
flow is a transcendental state of being
brain Imaging shows that when in flow
States we actually switch off the part
of the brain that gives us our sense of
self this part is called dorsolateral
frontal cortex it is the part of our
brain that allows us to analyze and
question our own behavior which can be
highly useful unfortunately it also
slows everything down because it means
that all our decisions have to go
through it and it can act as a creative
barrier by switching off this part we
allow all our attention to go to the
part we want to use without censorship
or micromanagement this results in quick
reactions and uninterrupted productivity
Flow State can be achieved with any task
and when reached each task becomes a
separate transcendental experience
and so all together I can't believe the
special stories that have been made up
about our relationship to the Universe
At Large because
they seem to be
too local too provincial the Earth he
came to the Earth
one of the aspects of God came to the
Earth mind you and look at what's out
there how can it isn't in proportion
depth as a concept has troubled me for
quite some time but I came to the
conclusion that Deputy strongly
associated with attention how
concentrated you can be while investing
your time in a specific task what we
choose to focus on and what we choose to
ignore is defining the quality of our
life skillful management of attention is
the Pinnacle of a good life our brains
are the ones that construct our
worldview based on what we pay attention
to who you are what you think feel and
do is the sum of what you focus on take
a moment to pause and reflect on that
sentence who you are what you think feel
and do is the sum of what you focus on
if you decide to focus on a shallow
interpretation of the world that doesn't
bring any meaning to your life you will
effectively adopt a more shallow
worldview our brains are very adaptable
in order to help us survive nowadays we
have a lot of freedom in choosing what
our brains will adapt to so consider for
a moment the type of mental World
constructed when you dedicate
significant time to deep Endeavors there
is gravity and a sense of importance
inherent in depth if you spend enough
time in that state your mind will
understand your world as rich in meaning
and importance when you're thinking
about something you don't understand you
have a terrible uncomfortable feeling of
confusion it's a very difficult and
unhappy business and so most of the time
you're rather unhappy actually with this
confusion you can't penetrate this thing
now is it the confusion is because we're
all some kind of Apes that are kind of
stupid working against this they're
trying to figure out to put the two
sticks together to reach the banana and
we can't quite make it the idea and I
get that feeling all the time that I'm
an ape trying to put two sticks together
so I always feel stupid once in a while
though everything the banana the sticks
go together on me and I reach the banana
[Music]
Feynman was Notorious for using peculiar
methods to solve complex problems and
also for constantly challenging people
in his New York Times best-selling book
surely you're joking Mr Fineman he tells
the story of going into the mathematics
Department of MIT and challenging people
to explain him difficult Concepts as
simply as they could he then managed to
explain the concept and reach the same
conclusions as they did his point was
that the ability of a person to simplify
difficult topics favors both the teacher
and the student the Feynman technique
was invented by a well-known blogger
Scott young Scott was inspired by
Richard feynman's method of learning and
created this technique so he can
understand difficult topics better it is
a two-step quite straightforward
technique that can be used to learn any
topic I am going to use the technique to
explain the concept of flow since it is
one of my favorite topics in our case I
will use the explanation of flow as it
is described in the Wikipedia entry in
positive psychology flow also known as
the zone is the mental state of
operation in which a person performing
an activity is fully immersed in a
feeling of energized Focus full
involvement and enjoyment in the process
of the activity in essence flow is
characterized by complete absorption and
what one does named by mihai Tik sent me
high the concept has been widely
referenced across a variety of fields
though has existed for thousands of
years under other guises notably in some
Eastern religions achieving flow is
often colloquially referred to as being
in the zone the concept here is kind of
simple so I don't think that it needs to
be read more than once in order to be
understood if we had to deal with
scientifically complex Concepts that
would include formulas and graphs we
might have needed to spend more time to
properly grasp
for the sake of practicality we will
keep it simple for a five-year-old the
terms positive psychology being in the
zone and energized Focus would most
probably be perceived as unknown terms
that means that we need to find even
simpler ways to describe it a great way
to go about doing so would be this you
know how sometimes people seem to
perform very well and we feel that they
are superhumans it happens with athletes
when they outperform their opponents it
happens with singers when they give
incredible performances and it happens
with writers when they produce amazing
literature this depends to some extent
on experience but it is also a result of
a process called flow flow is the state
where your mind can achieve great things
it is the time when you ignore all
external distractions and you're able to
give your full attention only to one
task this helps your brain understand
information faster and perform extremely
well in the task you're focused on this
is a pretty straightforward explanation
of an unknown topic that can really make
the topic stick I use Simple examples
like the ones of athletes singers and
writers and the Brain immediately makes
associations with relevant Concepts
Richard Feynman used to say I a universe
of atoms an atom in the universe we feel
so small and insignificant in this vast
place we call reality modern societies
seem unable to offer the level of
meaning demanded by our complicated
nature we second we find and we seek
again and we find again in the end we
rarely discover answers that can truly
satisfy our curiosity the next question
is bigger than the last one and the lack
of proper explanations creates an
intellectual and spiritual void making
better sense of reality can make us feel
less insignificant and that's something
worth fighting for
[Music]
hi guys this video is sponsored by
brilliant as you know I really do
sponsored videos but brilliant is such
an interesting platform and I couldn't
refuse when they approached me I think
that if Richard Feynman was alive he
would definitely enjoy brilliant's
approach to knowledge acquisition I have
tried many methods of learning over the
years but I'm almost certain that the
best way to learn anything is by doing
it yourself especially by learning
interactively Interactive Learning helps
you learn way more effectively than just
watching lecture videos Brilliance
platform is designed around this idea
take for instance this incredible course
on the physics of the everyday in this
course you can learn intuitively
Concepts like nuclear energy hurricanes
ax throwing even how toilets work the
structure is great and you can progress
from one topic to the next gradually and
seamlessly I got hooked and I was
playing around with the course for hours
I'm sure that brilliant is ideal for
students who want want to deeply
understand the STEM related topics but
it is also perfect for every curious
human who wants to delve into
interesting Concepts like astrophysics
Quantum objects logic and electricity
and magnetism to try everything
brilliant has to offer free for a full
30 days visit
brilliant.org
metamorphosis 77. the first 200 of you
will get 20 of Brilliance annual premium
subscription enjoy again thanks for
watching see you soon